SITTING AT 41 COMING INTO THISS.
BACK FOR WHEELER.F.
A BIG DRIVE BY SCHMIDT WITH AN .
WALMAN HEADING TO THE NET.
HE PU.
GOT IT AROUND THE AND HOLDS ON.
WELL, THE GOALTENDERS GET INTO .
HE HAD TO STOP AND PLAY THEAYED.
BACK TO SCHMIDT.
UP AHEAD FOR DUBOIS. BLAKE WHEE.
LINE.
EHLERS FEEDS IT BACK FOR PIONK.
NOW THE LONG PASS SVECHNIKOV.
WENT THROUGH HIS FEET.
MORGAN BARRON TO THE POINT.
DEMELO.
TIPPED AWAY BY
MORRISSESEOR SCHMIDT
WITH A FTER
SCHMIDT WITH AN
A LOT OF PLAYERS GO OUT AND
ENJOY THAT
IT'S CLOSE.
LOOKS OFFSIDE TO BE OFFSIDE.
>> ANDREW SMITH AND JUSTIN
JOHNSON THE LINESMEN
DYLAN LARKIN INTO THEE
THROUGH THEIR LEGS.
DETROIT HAS HAD
POKED IT AROUND FOR GAGNER.DUBO.
TRYING TO GO ACROSS FOR KYLE
CONNOR.
IT WAS TIPPED AWAY
DEMELO FOR CHIP IT OFF FOR STAA.
BACKSTAAL.
RASMUSSEN.
STOPPED BY HELLEBUYCK.
REBOUND T T
PUCK COMES IN FRONT.
LOOK OUT.
BACK TO THE POINT FOR WALMAN.
HANDS IT OFFHAKE OFF
WALMAN.
ERNE COMES IN LOOKING FOR A
LOOSE PUCK. SEIDER.
DOWN FOR ZADINA.
GOT IT IN
CLEARED AWAY.
GAGNER HAS GOT IT.
FLIPPED IT UP AHEAD AT IN FOR
O
PUCK.
LOOK AT HIM FIND IT.
HE BANGS IT IT.
PIONK UP FOR APPLETON.
DROPPED IT OFF FOR LOWRY. FOR S.
CREASE.
COMES BACK ACROSS FOR SCHEIFELE.
MARK SCHEIFELE IN FRONT, TIPPED
IT'S FLIPPED UP OVER THE GOAL AS
DeKEYSER TRYING TO CATCH UP TO